welcome everybody to the h3 podcast the
world's premiere podcast is that truth
when we say that now people are talking
about it on the streets if you ask
people on the street hey have you heard
they shoot podcast 99.9% of them will
say not 5.0 1% of the world's population
is probably a really big number I mean
technically speaking today's episode is
sponsored by nutri full and stamps com
Evo welcome to the show how are you
doing today good especially now that my
hair is covered I'm doing way better I
noticed that your work you think you're
having a bad hair day yeah that what's
going on uh-huh I don't think your hair
is bad I think your hair always look I
you know what's interesting about you
when you think you're having bad hair
days are some of the days I think your
hair looks the back doesn't that
interesting I don't know if it's a worse
you know does it make things worse for
me know what it just means is that like
the way that we see ourselves in the
mirror is has absolutely no relation
whatsoever to how people see us in the
world maybe I feel like that's that
that's just that's just plainly true I
found that to be true in my own life
right a book can start a cult whoa okay
Cole I mean I recall that be fantastic
air cool air cult firm in no but it's
true like when you look in the mirror
everybody has these little quarks right
they they're just used to seeing
themselves a certain way so when it's
off you're like oh I look awful but
really everybody in the world sees you
the same way do just think about
everybody you know you don't look at
them and be like oh he looks like [ __ ]
today they're like no that's the same
person I said yesterday there is a
variance yeah but usually it's based on
the range it's a small range and it's
based on really like clothing and mood
more than anything it's not like oh they
look like [ __ ] today you know what I
mean like how harsh do you judge
yourself when you look in the mirror
like when I see any of these guys or you
it's like that's ela that's Dan that's
that's in don't like oh dude you know I
know but you're an enlightened guru no
that's good I'm spearhead movement no
you saying start to call it yeah are you
signing up I did that was consent to my
cult at the merit and do you mind if I
[ __ ] other women because that's kind of
a big deal about being a glass not not
the hair cult but we don't do that oh we
don't but what's the point having a cult
if I can [ __ ] other all my everyone
else's wife in session light and people
how some how every call no matter what
it's about
or who it is the head of the cult is
somehow [ __ ] everybody's wife that has
nothing to do with it of course they're
like listen to it God told me to [ __ ]
your wife bro every cool it's crazy it's
awesome
it's an awesome thing about colds and
the dudes are like cool I mean God said
[ __ ] my wife so just go for it bro it's
an honor it's an honor you honor me yeah
Vin Diesel what are we doing here why
are we here today on this gracious
Friday Saturday for you watching it I
hope everybody's staying safe I hope
everybody is uh what do we do you know I
don't know what to do I'm talking about
the covet thing I'm not gonna talking to
I'm just talking spiritually I just feel
so bad for everyone you know like all
these protesters like here in California
in New York everything's locked down but
all around the country people just wanna
get back to work cuz they're broke and
they have nothing no option so I feel so
I just feel badly for everybody you know
I just I don't know I just wish everyone
the best that's it and we are and
remember if you want $500 for free
on Twitter every day we are giving out
$500 of cash to three people every day
like they are we on now 32 I think yeah
yeah
there's crazy house like long 100 days
yeah but there you go you still there's
a still a lot of cash
up for grabs so congratulations to all
the winners now you know what speaking
of kovat we had done a segment about so
Flo Antonio about how he's in South
Korea in the bars livin it up
I know and let me should pull up this
clip to refresh everybody's memory is
that we saw him in the bar and we're
like how is this [ __ ] that was
just last week I was like wait did it
how like they're sharing bottles peek
pandemic
let me show I need to mute it you took
no fun anymore it's like oh do I need to
mute this guy breathing but anyway he's
in these clubs sharing bottles with
people apparently they're wearing masks
but they're all around there now people
are not I mean they have masks on but
they're not wearing them properly you
know but so Flo let me ask you why would
you record you sharing a bottle with
somebody during a pandemic I mean in
South Korea too that just seems that
just seems over-the-top what about it's
so crowded it's you know it's like a
nightclub yelling is shoulder to
shoulder I'm surprised that that this is
going on in South Korea but they're way
ahead of this pandemic way more than we
are but okay against South Korea knows
what they're doing and then sure enough
I saw this headline and I was like holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] listen to this headline
spike in South Korea infections linked
to one man's night out I was like holy
[ __ ] so flows the super spreader this
hole has once again closed down its bars
and nightclubs after an increase in
corona virus infection was linked back
to one
South Korean capitals entertainment
district most new cases have been traced
back to one man holy [ __ ] so close
[ __ ] it not only not only the place
America that he had to bounce to South
Korea now he's super spreading in South
Korea where is he gonna go next
isn't that so funny jeez if I mean damn
if I'm on just on Instagram being like
ooh that doesn't look safe yeah I hope
that South Korea government would be
more ahead of it than me on instagrams
the stories but there you have it so so
so Flo has shut down all nightlife in
South Korea it's awesome just a prank
bro I mean listen they add up it says a
20 year old man tested positive for the
corona but how it is so fun maybe that's
older than I looked at that leaf not
ages don't match I like knows it so Flo
yeah I want to believe it too but 29
year old man tested positive for the
corona virus after visiting several
clubs and bars there that weekend it's
crazy
25
I think he's 29
he's 25 he's 29 no I'm just kidding
so that was that was funny that was very
funny you know that's right how funny
all right how funny was that I will get
that like I mean they'd be funny big
funny my initial reaction to the
headline was like that's funny so I
don't know how you rate that on a scale
of one to ten but pretty high funny no
medium high funny about a way funnier
than this conversational funny it is how
do we get mobility marry back on the
radar because this we found him a new
mobility marry video we haven't seen
Zack just came up with this clip out of
nowhere
you know it's on my channel a youtube
channel called the ghost of Mobile named
Harry she's awesome it was on the
subreddit Zak you gonna have to comb
through this channel and find find other
ones we haven't seen I was so happy to
see to see her again
I miss her she just stopped posting
videos and I hope she's okay you know
the the crazy thing about mobility Mary
is that she's in Santa Monica so like
the the chance of us hunting her down
there or pretty high yeah like if I took
my scooter down there and just cruised
around there's a good chance we cross
paths in can you watch every video on
this channel you pick out the goldies
sure thing that was Ian I said oh I'm
sorry I thought I said Zach okay great
so I don't have to do that no Ian is
yeah I have an on some top-secret work I
didn't even want to say anything more or
not so Zach can you what can you blitz
splurge on the mobility marry thank you
I wouldn't be happy to thank you so much
all right listen listen joy I mean this
is a treasure like I feel like when
you're a treasure hunter goes and finds
a shipwreck and brings up these like
rare Spanish coins you know that's what
we have here so without further ado my
friends I bring you Whole Foods parking
lot idiot and handicapped area by
mobility Mary
ability Mary is just cruising up the
whole foods and there's people
chit-chatting and this blue area
what's huge by the way he's a whole food
employee I'm pretty sure to parking lot
is wide open doesn't miss Abby how about
if I call the police you're insane
welcome to mobile bet you're in mobility
Mary's world now [ __ ]
by the way this conversation is taking
place in a huge empty parking lot yeah
she has no trouble going any there I
know there's like 30 feet wide
handicapped crossing and it's completely
empty
oh really yeah you're insane I'm out
here doing my job no but you're doing it
illegally good okay let's just see
so then she charges in and it ends
abruptly but it looks like she was about
to jihad the whole foods she's a true
she's a national treasure and we miss
her dearly ability marry man you know my
fit is just great that he's actually
he's an employee like take a look at the
guy oh yeah yeah it's awesome he's
really barely in the you know you know
maybe that maybe she Paris did you did a
suicide bombing the Whole Foods there
cuz she at the end she's like let's see
what happens and she charges in hey
what's this man she's gonna drive him to
all the water that's what I thought she
wouldn't put herself in risk no mobility
marry where are you why would you leave
us at a time like this when we need you
most
it's like bat the bat signals up and
nobody's coming for home the scooter
signal is up mobility what would I
wonder what moat what god I would love
to just give her reality show I mean
seriously just bring some cameras follow
her around that put that on TLC call it
like my mobile my my mobility life you
know oh [ __ ] guys I bring you good news
the Colombians have invented a bed that
turns into a coffin this [ __ ] is just so
dark and I just found myself laughing at
just how about what a [ __ ] mess we're
in here and just how dark to imagine
just imagine if you would for a second
that you go to the hospital and they put
your ass on a [ __ ] cardboard bed that
doubles as a coffin
you're like oh dude I do not like my
odds right now I don't like what this
says about my stay here in this hospital
[Music]
bro
here it is watch this it's great
Columbian design companies making
cardboard hospital beds cardboard coffin
like your ass is being shipped FedEx can
easily be turned into a coffin if the
patient dies sweet you just push down
lower that there's a live person there
dead these cardboard beds are made for
people with coronavirus just remember to
fold the lip and that means that if the
patient dies medics good enough to move
the body I mean it put the FedEx label
on top
right prepaid envelope it's awesome able
to hold up to 150 kilograms of body
weight that's impressive
hospital beds and coffin during short
supply in the state of the Amazon there
you have it we are
it's impressive
we've got 3000 of these babies coming a
day and there goes one poor soul he's
being shipped off to so crazy
he's being returned to Amazon I want a
refund on my life I love this shot I
found myself just giggling about this
image because it's just so like this
dude's dead right apparently and they're
like all right peace that's a good idea
I'm not gonna hate on the idea it's just
a little [ __ ] up no but it's funny you
know but I just love when your ass hits
the hospital make sure you if you get
that cardboard bed boy you better plug
in you better say your prayers because
your ass is getting FedExed overnight
into the earth you are getting a
priority shipping ground at UPS
underground you fia's underground no
signature required straight into the
earth overnight thank you race come
think it's time for your first read well
thank you to a new sponsor of ours nutri
full nutri full baby it's a pill you
take every day that strengthens your
beautiful hair
80 million men and women in the u.s.
experiencing thinning hair yet we are
still not talking openly about the
problem it's scary is stressful and it
just adds to problems control isn't
given it's taken take charge of your
hair growth and make the next few months
your time to grow thicker fuller healthy
here at a time with self care is more
important than ever every day is an
opportunity to just skip damaging
styling tools and chemicals and focus on
better hair growth from within oh good
good point you know it's about your own
responsibility for your hair as well
millions of Americans experience
thinning hair it's common it's even
normal but it's not openly talked about
so going through it can feel lonely and
frustrating it's time to change the
conversation and join thousands of
people standing up for their strands
with nutria ful nutria ful is formulated
with potent both botanicals to help you
grow hair as strong as you are you are a
big beautiful strong man or woman and
it's physician formulated to be 100%
drug-free nutria full physicians
formulated to be 100 percent drug-free
folks I'll say it again they use natural
clinically effective botanicals for
better hair growth throughout the whole
body on top of thicker stronger hair
without laser or chemicals neutrophils
ingredients may also help you get a
handle on better sleep stress response
skin nails and libido visit neutrophil
calm and take their hair wellness quiz
for customized product recommendations
to put the power to grow thicker
stronger hair back into your hands and
when you subscribe you'll receive
monthly deliveries so you never miss
adèle shipping is free and you can pause
it cancel anytime does it work
yes and clinical studies nutri full
users saw thicker stronger hair growth
with less shedding and three to six
months whether you're experiencing
thinning or not you deserve hair as
strong as you are
neutrophil can help you achieve your
best hair growth naturally you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to neutrophil dot-com and
use the promo code h3 to get 20% off
this is their best offer available
anywhere plus free shipping on every
order get 20% off at nutria full calm
promo code h3 this is the best offer
you're ever gonna find spelled n UT are
a fol comm promo code h3 for hair as
strong as you are
I asked for embarrassing
talks and I received embarrassing tip
time I'm very happy to introduce to you
all our first one guy dumps giant gallon
of cereal on Subway as a quote prank
this really brings me back doesn't it to
the good old days of YouTube imagine if
you would please that there's in the
middle of a pandemic
people are already uneasy about being on
the subway
there are cleanup crews going through to
sanitize and this this [ __ ] [ __ ] I
mean what can you say about this guy I'm
just gonna play it for you first
accidentally dropped on this subway
today but I was like can someone help
surprisingly no one offered so I had to
put all the soggy cereal back in myself
someone was like I cannot believe this
is happening I was like I can't believe
this is happening again
thank yo you're such a douche and I like
how he thinks he's an app is sort of
like a rest of development you know no
dude you're just on the subway car and
everybody hates you you know but just
imagine like you did let me tell you
something the people who work for the
subway system in New York City people
die people who work for the subway
system have died okay they're literally
putting their lives on the line and
they're frontline workers and for them
to go in there and have to sanitize the
this cart and clean up your [ __ ] bro you
should be [ __ ] what do we do with him
what's bad enough for him what do we do
I'm gonna put you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna put his ass in a [ __ ]
cardboard coffin and send his ass
Express underground overnight what do we
do to this guy what's bad enough to do
this guy dan what do we do with him
should have to you should have to clean
it up you should have to eat it
he's going on it that's a fair
punishment that's a good fair punishment
I think he's asking needs to be put to
work sanitizing subway carts at the
reality yeah I really hope that the
authorities I mean he's clearly
identified himself he is a [ __ ] Joshi on
tick tock appropriately named so the
authorities should be able to track him
down for a why why would you do this man
and by the way he got it and let me just
let's watch and he got it on homie shoes
yeah let's go back to the beginning and
do a play-by-play watching the podcast
back last year and I clear my throat a
lot and its really annoying so apologies
just one I need to turn away you can't
drink yeah I know the coffee's does bad
for me okay so homies on the subway drop
dude he gets it all he gets it he gets
it all over their pants and shoes look
at that splash zone homies jeans has
milk and cereal on it now this guy needs
to get his ass beat I feel like somebody
on the train needs to be it just slap
him can we get behind violence physical
violence or no no physical violence if
somebody slapped him would you still
post the video oh yeah
dan can I can somebody slap him or is
that a no just a bitch-slap not like not
like it
can somebody slapping I've been saying
is it wrong is it wrong to wish somebody
to bitch-slap this guy
no thank you
I think it's maybe wrong for you to say
it on the
I'm not saying one of our fans to go
hunt him down I mean on the subway if
somebody was like dude you deserve a
bitch-slap for that who got milk on
their shoes like I'm the tough guy I
wouldn't do that
I want a bitch-slap anybody okay
I'm just saying it sounds like you're
saying someone should go home no I'm not
saying that no no no no no no no no no
that's not what I'm saying let me make
that explicitly clear physical violence
is never the answer and let me also say
that I'm a [ __ ] and I cower away from
physical violence at any every
opportunity that it's presented to me I
am a coward and a [ __ ] and I definitely
want to bitch-slap this kid I'd probably
just feel like I'd probably just walk
silently off like they did to be honest
I look on the New York subway [ __ ]
happens and like you don't even want to
know like you don't want to go down you
don't know this is just some corny Viner
like this could be you want to go into
their world on the New York subway [ __ ]
gets weird and all of a sudden you you
know I mean this guy's got a grenade in
his pocket and he's talking about trying
to kill toucan sam what's the name of
the guy from fruity pebbles yeah that's
Duke and Sam yeah he's talking about
jihad Angie Kenton if we're all pissed
about - Ken Sam they redesigned him this
past week oh oh well let's look into
that you want to see new take a look at
new toucan sam - kids - can't Sam is our
Froot Loops
yeah didn't you say Froot Loops yeah
pretty used to fruity pebble Oh huge
difference big difference and to all my
homies with hairy backs this one struck
out to me this one's actually not from
tik-tok I found this just casually
browsing Instagram and I was like
there's like a whole new genre on
Instagram videos of barbers doing like
crazy fades and stuff so I expected to
see the dude get his back shaved or
something but what I did see shocked me
we're gonna have to remove the audio
from this but here and what I found was
a was the dude was just getting like
blow-dried his back I was just getting
blow-dried this really like I was too
insane to be real what the back air the
blow dryer back her that's real back
hair and blowdry the blow John I'm not
sure if people go and get their back
hair done you know they look good is
bleached tips that's definitely real
back here though where's the shoulder I
guess so clean he shaved that you know
so this nut doesn't show over the
hairline Dan barbers put up with a lot
of [ __ ] like I can't imagine I can't
imagine blow-drying a dude's back hair
like so casually as he is you know I
guess we got that much back hair you
better you better glow up you know it's
crazy yeah
salt Bay insult Bay keeps coming up on
my feet I've talked about him a lot he's
obsessed with when he he's obsessed when
he comes out with the steak and it went
anytime some girl with like big titties
comes to his restaurant he insists on
putting the meat on the edge of a knife
and feeding them and what seems to be
like a forced sexual act but that but
the girls seem down but this one struck
out to me because this one's a little
kid he's forced eating and I'm just I'm
kind of so over sulfate like first of
all can we all agree that this is no way
to season your food especially if you've
got a nice steak I mean this is just no
way to season your food he just dumped a
pound of salt on it right
and so he's gonna he's not using the
knife but his dirty ass meat gloves is
going right into the kid's mouth and of
course she doesn't want it you're a
weird dude and his knife is pointing at
her too like isn't that etiquette not to
point your knife of people imagine the
strange man is trying to force me into
her mouth with a dirty glove and his
knife is pointing at you I'm not
enjoying this I don't like that the
parents are so excited about it though
take the meat look at me with the knife
yeah I can't get enough assault bay but
I do not recommend seasoning your food
like that goddamn it it's starting to
piss me off with the shoulder sprinkle
enough salt Bay next eel I've got new
bad tattoos free drape this one's been
showing up in my feet a lot and I just
need to get your take on it
the two it has like honestly a really
impressive so bad it's impressive
so the guy's got like a black hole on
his dome and it's really impressively
done from a 3d point of view although if
you look at it from my other angle what
it know only from this one angle so that
I'd like to see it from any other angle
it probably looks quite quite weird you
don't like that one you wouldn't approve
well the good news about the dome just
grow your hair you can just grow your
hair out Sam I'd hate to run either back
on the New York subway with a with a tub
of cereal
I'd be like holy [ __ ] what is he gonna
do it that cereal okay so how does this
fit is this worse than Ben's is this the
worst
I don't know who the guy is he's just
like it's actually Kevin Costner you
can't tell me that I really hate it when
I actually see a worse tattoo because it
runs the magic but this is kind of the
worst
what do you guys think do you think it's
kind of cool you can't see it god damn
it well you know I have a pulled up I
see it
so what every night is it cool or is it
the worst tattoo ever like it's good
execution from mean obviously like you
said it only works from one particular
angle like if you were to rotate around
the back of this guy's head a little bit
it would beyond that it's just such a
visual nightmare all these black on your
head yeah it's kind of like scary it
makes you feel uncomfortable
it's like body [ __ ] yeah like a skull
has been like smashed in it just is like
how [ __ ] up and you dude that you're
willing to put that on your home but
like yeah again I mean I guess credit to
the artist for successfully you know
getting the optical illusion to work
absolutely right I mean the shading is
good it scrape the lines are all there
you know yeah if we ever get divorced to
ela this is what I'm gonna do no more
can do yeah you don't control me anymore
and then there was another phenomenon I
noticed people are getting covet 19
tattoos and I don't get it are we are we
memorializing how do you say it when
they saw those like commemorative coins
commemorative yeah commemorative kovin
19 tattoos but it's like well as you'll
see I guess we should look at them first
but they're they're all they're all just
honoring like the first week of the
pandemic really right I mean you guys
can't you can't commemorate something
that isn't over yet right so people are
getting Korona night toilet paper so
I guess that's funny but golly why would
you want and toilet paper tattoo on you
well and as you'll see this is what I
was hinting out there and they're almost
all toilet paper thing that was only
like the first week like there's toilet
paper now it's it's it's not hard to
find some other paper anymore this one
is the toilet paper tattoo
well never forget never forget man you
ever gone a week without wiping your ass
dance I don't think so did anyone really
have a full week of no toilet paper
probably somewhere this guy might have
you got a tattoo about it I don't think
people really got to that point did you
guys ever get dangerously low on toilet
paper oh yeah I don't use it so I
wouldn't know I need to revisit you wash
your ass I use baby still after
everything we've learned on the show
yeah monstering the sewage monster I
don't care you are destroying their
plumbing no no the truth is that yeah it
doesn't destroy the houses plumbing it
just destroys the city its plumbing oh
okay what were those things called like
the giant fat bird bird balls the fat
bird or whatever fat burger so we have
got some of your [ __ ] building up in the
city fatberg bro that's [ __ ] up we've
we've come so I thought we have come
further than yeah I thought like the arc
of this lesson I thought as a show there
was a learning curve here yeah at
paradigm shift no I'm not actually don't
use anything I am zero I'm just all bad
a good day man I mean how much Ethan has
grown remember what this all started yes
Scott you were discussion
not even a soul journey yeah ol sickle
and cyclical dream the bidet I have even
dries my ass yeah yeah yeah looks my
fiancee and I just come all over my
knees it puts in a pro about my ass I
feel like I don't have time to dry I go
it takes too long it's still long
anything is there for like 30 minutes it
doesn't you get over the tickle on your
butthole like yeah maybe at first at the
first like a couple times you're like oh
my favorite thing about it is the warm
seat warm seat warm water Wow
but it's funny cuz we got we do we got
it just before the pandemic and like
such a crazy timing cuz we actually I
should get a tattoo with a Madonna 19 so
anyway this guy said to is a corona beer
with a lime on top and viruses inside of
the bottle with a Corona 19 this kind of
looks like a dagger I think it's
supposed meant to be like a parody of
like the dagger tattoo that you
sometimes see coronavirus survivor with
a roll of toilet paper well it's a
little immature yeah I don't wanna cry
nobody you can't call yourself a
survivor you got plenty of time to drop
I can't think of a worse item to want to
be tattooed on me forever
than toilet paper like it's just the
worst it's visually boring reminds me of
poop I would imagine that these people
aren't too concerned about the
real-estate value like they probably
have a shitload of tats you just get
smelted in there you know
here is a very intricate drawing of a
virus looking like a Disney style
holding a toilet paper here is kovat 19
on toilet paper
survived
you didn't survive bro it says survive
with a virus with a mask that says kovin
19 bro you did not survive you cannot
get that how'd you even get the tattoo
I thought businesses are not open like
non-essential you you specifically
didn't survive because you're out
getting tattoos I mean your ass is gonna
be in a cardboard box before the end of
the year I'm sure of it
UPS underground this one is just a
really colorful purple yellow and red
virus an ass one looks like it says Kobe
thirteen wait which one the nine looks
like a three I think they're that far
yet say oh yeah this one is another
Corona golly you got you guys got to
stop doing this stop doing this please
covert 13 yeah so is this a joke
what am I did they really get a tattoo
and sake ovid 13 they got the number
wrong so the mask and it just as close I
mean maybe it was intentional like that
looks like the leg the back of the leg
bro you have covered 13 and everybody
who sees me like dude over 13 you're so
dog I'll have to fix that you could like
finish the social distancing butterfly a
roll of toilet paper
Wow a fall out this one is somewhat
original we've got a fall out a
character with half skeleton and a
toilet paper roll covered 19 and so he's
[ __ ] blood and a bat hanging on his
arm kovat 19 does not make you [ __ ]
blood as I'm aware but don't tell what I
think that's just a trail oh okay okay
okay apologies for misinterpreting more
toilet paper
more corona more staying alive at least
he didn't claim to survive it I mean
these are getting exhausting there's way
too many of these are so awful okay
well I'm getting a tattoo on my forehead
that says Cova 19 survivor that's the
best way to make sure you die from this
we are we are past time for our second
break well then the other let's give a
big warm thank you to stamps.com
and what a better time to use stamps
calm then now let's avoid crowds but we
need to mail stuff right so if you need
to send postage and letters and packages
out use stamps calm anything you can do
at the post office you can do at stamps
calm printing postage on demand and
skipping lines and crowds at the post
office plus you actually save money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office Samsa compras you all the
services of the US Postal Service write
to your computer and the safety and
comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you are hunkering down in
right now whether your small business
sending invoices and online sellers
shipping our product or you're just
working from home and need to mail stuff
stamps calm can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free pickup and drop it off
at a mailbox no human contact required
it's that simple and like I said with
stamps comm you get great discounts to
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off usps shipping rates
and now in addition to offering
discounted US Postal Service rates
stamps.com is also offering UPS service
UPS services with discounted rates up to
62 percent well that is our Aegis plus
with Samsung comm you won't even have to
pay UPS residential surcharges wasn't
aware of those or a thing but hey
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time money and keeping
you safe in these crazy times so for our
listeners right now get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
h3 that's stamps.com
enter h3 stay safe my friends thank you
to our sponsor
so 90-day fiance before the 90 days is a
show that is dear and near and close to
our heart big Edie friend of the show
obviously in close contact with him
they put a tight lid on on big head
though could these they've got they've
got ad on a short leash but let me tell
you Jeffery okay the guy that we spoke
about in our last show who went to
Russia to find a bride in the newest
episode she rejected his engagement yeah
which was pretty epic because we found
out that he has a rich criminal history
that she didn't know at the time but
Jeffery it's this is so epic you guys we
are coming we are becoming so entangled
with the cast of this show
Jeffrey addressed us on Instagram live
video sort of that's sort of but I'm
thinking maybe we can get Jeffery we got
to reach out to Jeffery mm-hmm because I
feel like you they can't control Jeffery
he's off the rails big Edie Big Ed
scared alright Big Ed cares he wants to
be a part of the of the show because
Jeffrey he's already been banned from
the reunion mm-hmm
they've already kicked Jeffery out of
the club so they've got nothing on Jeff
we have to get Jeffery to call him Zach
figure that out you're the guy to do
that I will get on if you need me to
follow him are you gonna watch it yeah
he's gonna do with the nipple tats if
you need me to follow him on my account
message him I'll do that too we're come
at at all angles okay but here he is on
livestream addressing all the
allegations because people were saying
he was a spousal abuse er we we had said
that that's what I heard and Jeffery is
attempting to correct the record here on
the livestream so
holy smokes all these people ripped up
all these views and all these clicks
that you clicked on for money that they
made because you read it and you looked
at it and you questioned me and it was
small based on rumors and lies isn't
that amazing how that works just think
about that for my my life right now okay
a lot of what you're reading is based on
lies and rumors made fictitional BS and
rumors it made me happy
and I'm watching the show who was sad in
a sense but it also made me happy it's
kind of crazy
I heard a story he seems like a little
loose little easier I don't mind I don't
want to call the guy crazy but he seemed
a little or maybe drunk or something he
might be drunk and but he's the ezel but
let's hear the guy see all this smack
out there is such [ __ ] realize that
you know everything you're reading it
just well it's just it's just meant for
my money it's fake news you know it is
fake news well a date another Russian
everyone makes mistakes I did pay my
mother you still have those nipple tests
I do still have the nipple tat so that's
not so Geoffrey is obviously upset about
the allegations the thing is that the
nipple tats offend me more than the
spousal abuse and that's not fake news
but I looked into acquisition oh well
Jeffrey the last thing I want to do is
accuse or insinuate in any way that
that he's guilty of any kind of crime
that I mean obviously I was reporting on
something else someone else had reported
on so we looked into it let's see he he
confessed on the show to serving time in
prison more than 20 years ago that's a
long time for dealing drugs and frankly
that didn't offend me that much that the
guy got I could have gone to jail for
selling drugs that sound like much at
all yeah I was actually really rooting
for him on the show yeah I was like man
this is [ __ ] everyone's making a
crime seem like such a big deal but
that's not the only legal trouble he's
been in he's also been indicted by a
grand jury late last year for aggravated
kidnapping domestic assault interference
with emergency call vandalism after a
girlfriend alleged that he had violently
grabbed her by the neck and slammed her
head into the wall
according to court documents obtained by
oxygen.com so I'm not making this up I
mean I don't know if the claims are true
or not but I'm not just making [ __ ] up
out of thin air but I'd love to hear
Jeffrey's side of the story the reality
stars criminal past and the current
allegations against him even prompted
some TLC fans to start a change.org
petition see I'm not I'm not signing any
petitions Jeffery I just want you to
know that remove him from TLC shows well
they did boot him but hey I'm not I'm
not signing this petition I ain't got
all the facts here Jeff well look at the
signatures going up this thing is active
you guys
well serving time he was arrested in
1990 in Tennessee for possession of a
scheduled six is their scheduled six
controlled substance
how many schedules are there yeah what
the [ __ ] is the schedule six six are
drugs that have a relatively low
potential for abuse
oh so the guy was selling weed probably
or something even weed is Schedule one
which is insane
it is
well maybe I'm wrong about that it's
like way higher than it should be so
schedule six what is says yo six Advil
threatening he pleaded guilty to the
charges against him most sentenced to 11
months man they threw the book at him
for sewing a bunch yeah no here it is
marijuana is also a class 1 ok Schedule
one drug
despite it being legal in some states
that's crazy so schedule ones like
heroin cocaine and all that crazy [ __ ]
heroin LSD cocaine and and bro so what
the [ __ ] is a schedule six yeah alright
well here's the thing as scheduled I
just go get scheduled six includes
marijuana which is a lower risk of
physical dependency in contracts with
many other drugs I love that it's you
they're looking at I love that marijuana
it's either one or six well you I think
is it a state-by-state thing or is it a
federal that's a federal talk about the
way marijuana and salvia that's what I'm
reading aside yeah well you got to
remember this is also in Tennessee to so
wait what's the schedule six and salvia
salvia you can buy that [ __ ] at a
headshot but that's no not anymore they
got rid of that oh okay wait hold up
where I wouldn't recommend it either to
anybody I fit it straight up that [ __ ]
is really still sell salvia and [ __ ]
head jobs dude haven't been a headshot
in a decade I don't know it's been a
while for me too but that's great Anya
so that should is that head shop is so
cringy it's like the rite of passage of
any teenager when you walk in you're
like oh [ __ ] it smells like nan choppa
what is that [ __ ] they always burn
knock knock Champa I always mix up
incest in incense once [ __ ] your
brother and one's a nice pleasant
smelling aroma very different and one is
what mean ela do alright
which is the nice aroma no my brothers
and sisters and one smells like Zach
burns it in his room do you burn incense
and incense do you burn incense yeah
I do not know I do oh I got a box of nog
chomp at home you gotta bro bro let's
hit some salvia that trick so [ __ ] up
so what the hell this guy went to jail
for a year for selling Advil scheduled
sick dude I'm still confused I'm on the
DEA what DEA gov on this drug scheduling
and there is no schedules so look for
Tennessee must be Tennessee look up
Tennessee scheduled six controlled
substance
it says marijuana and salvia any
including poppers ro he was selling
poppers brother [ __ ] year he must
have had a lot right like why would they
charge him for that I mean I don't know
if Tennessee's crazy
why didn't I just wish because in the
show he's always like I've changed I'm
different why don't you just say I was
selling popper like I wasn't even hard
drug didn't year prison twenty years ago
I wouldn't hold that against the guy
okay alright let's move on
Marion O'Bryant public information
officer declined to provide details
about the arrest
all right fascinating so this is that
this is the allegation that troubles me
the drug selling I don't care about in
fact I feel bad for him
victim of the war on drugs as they say
but what hasn't been addressed on the
show is his domestic violence arrest in
2019 his girlfriend at the time called
9-1-1 to report that she had allegedly
been attacked by him the woman told
authorities that he was intoxicated
grabbed her by the neck and slammed her
head against the wall several times that
sounds horribly violent and a later
petition filed to seek an order of
protection she said he repeatedly bashed
slammed her head into the hardwood floor
Jesus
here's an article about it that I guess
happened at the time oh it's just old
news just kind of the same [ __ ] we just
read he dragged me through the house by
the hair and continued throwing my body
until walls and furniture cheese's I
know this because of blood on the walls
furniture etc she also told authorities
that he disabled her phone so she
couldn't call for help
paramedic who arrived at the scene
determined that the woman exhibited
common signs of a concussion was taken
to a local hospital by her neighbor for
further medical evaluation over said the
scene also noted that he had scratch
marks on his stomach and chest which
appeared to be self-inflicted how could
you tell if they were self-inflicted or
not I think they can tell he appeared at
an arraignment on the charges in January
and told the Knoxville News Sentinel
that he was not guilty he believed his
ex-girlfriend had pursued the charges
because of a pending child custody case
involving another woman he also
addressed the allegations against him in
a recent Instagram post that we have
since wash so what do you make of that
it sounds like the professionals who
showed up on the scene the forensic
evidence did not support his claim seems
like the forensic evidence supported the
woman's claim that he had violently
harmed her the self-inflicted wounds is
weird because that does that imply that
he had like DNA under his nails that
they could that like I mean super crazy
if he actually self-inflicted wounds on
his chest and stomach to make it look
like she yeah that doesn't sound good
Jeffrey I got to tell you man I'm I read
that open do hoping to exonerate you
because I wanted to see the best but boy
that actually made me more scared of you
and actually I don't really want to talk
to him on the shell anymore after
reading that so what do you think's when
you said that I was like I hope he's not
serious well I well I thought well you
you know yeah no I don't I this sounds
really bad this sounds really bad
capsule they call it answer the call
damn that sounds crazy my boy Jeff I
mean look how Saint can you be when you
have nipple tats ultimately look no I'm
serious you listen he's got full flame
nipple tax like I mean who do you
believe the guy with nipple tats I
haven't seen her no good point we
haven't seen judgment yes the girl
because on well from what was presented
on the show it seemed like they were
having a great time and he was just
being nice
you know and everything so when he
proposed and she was like I'm not ready
I was surprised but we know more than
she knew at the time right and if I
don't know if she read between the lines
if she saw stuff they don't show you
know in that it's but such an
interesting the season is just insane
it's it's like the best television right
now it's the best reality season of any
show I've ever seen and it's not over
yet I agree with you because at first my
first impression was like oh she's such
a she's just trying to get to America
she's on the site dating specifically
for American guys and then you find out
before all this that she's talking to
other American guys right and you're
like oh men you're on his side all the
way but I think what happened was
probably that she just she wanted to be
nice and nots
they were she didn't want to spoil the
time together but I think she probably
would immediately it was like this guy's
[ __ ] crazy you know I guess so
fascinating I mean guys you got to watch
before the 90 day but Jeffrey's off the
chain right now he's handles his
handlers of lost control don't you know
this now in I want specifically you to
weigh in on this because you are our pop
culture you're dialed in so in tell me
what you think about DoDEA cat promising
that she will show her boobs if her song
say so reached number one her song
reached number one and Sherine it it
would I don't want to what's the word
REE net to renegotiate renege right
renege yeah and then she reneged on her
promise now in what D what is your let
me let me bring everyone up to date here
first okay before you weigh in she
tweeted out if say so hit someone I'll
show you guys my boobs really hard
400,000 likes fifty thousand retweets
people go crazy trying to get it number
one I gotta mute this real fast but ela
take note of this this guy goes on it
and he's playing it on what can only be
described as 50/50 phones and computers
and televisions this guy wants to see
those titties real bad song did reach
number one Nicki Minaj saying thank you
and asking when are you showing them
titties girl because Nicki Minaj is a
girl of the streets and frankly word is
bond where the she comes from and if
you're not if your word isn't your bomb
then then what is exactly um what is
your bond right and so here's her video
saying that no she will not be making
good on her prom
so titties I just realized I have to
show my boobs real hard I'm just gonna
be honest with you guys I did play you
I'm not showing my boobs real hard man
you [ __ ] played
you got [ __ ] played look at yourself
well I have to say that it's I frankly
just think it's not right that she would
make such a claim and took and to just
clearly read renege on on an agreement
when people rode for her Nicki Minaj
who's a girl of the street by the way
looks like a fool now and and really I
just feel like doja cat whoever she I'm
not even familiar with her has lost all
credibility and the next time people are
gonna think twice about any promises she
makes Ian what is your take on this uh I
mean you know if she promises to show
him again and you're still giving her
credibility I think you kind of goofed a
little bit it seems people that believed
her kind of deserve to get played
why what do you say that did you do this
before is this a no but I mean come on
why come on you would expect to see some
titties I would expect a Twitter post of
just titties to assume - why would
people it's just what would people think
that that was a disingenuous offer cuz
it wasn't like I'll show my it wasn't
that crazy like I'll show my boobs like
that seems reasonable it wasn't like I
was that's what is crazy to you like oh
I'll do I'll do a DP video I mean I
don't know
titties ain't that crazy I mean then if
she said if she said I'm gonna post a DP
you'll go no that's awesome stop calling
for that yeah but titties is very
believable that's like being it's a very
it's a very reasonable thing to offer
for a number one hit I think but you you
you are defending dojo can you think
that people were
foolish to believe that she would show
her titties I think people were a little
foolish yeah I think people got played
in her words yeah so Ian's take is it
seems like people keep getting playing
like with Belle Delphine
they got played and they got upset that
was you know what that wasn't a lot she
was doing a good good doja Kat lied I'm
gonna defend I'm gonna defend Belle
Delphine here real quick
she said I'm gonna do horns and she put
up all the eyes she says I look like
videos on pornhub and she she you riding
for Belle Delphine what is what a
shocker
yeah but don't you can't just
straight-up lied are you simple right
now I've never paid dolt bailed
everything in dollar because you're
Belle Delphine subscription so active
what's going on over there
Zak is a mom's the word Zak will keep it
we'll keep it quiet
just between us that's between us boys
talk to me baby listen I like just show
it I don't think she play it I know I
frankly think it's not right I think she
owes the world a titty shine it's not
like putting out fredo sauce up your
butt exactly that's what I mean it's not
that far-fetched she owes the world a
titty shot and in this day and age you
have these pop stars they're basically
just like they show everything yeah I
mean they're almost naked anyway already
I demand to see them titties people
didn't get played like that one guy with
all those cranes yeah I mean that guy
deserves titties like there's a bunch of
articles about she lied let's see Nicki
Minaj asked doe Jacquet to deliver on
her breasts showing challenge
oof she admits she lied
Daily Mail toad you can't reveal she
lied Wow tough Nicki Minaj wants to see
them titties does you kind of miss she
played fans about showing boobs damn
don't you count lied about showing her
titties mmm
she admit it while everybody picked up
the story huh horny men are upset that
doja cat trolled them with the promise
of boobs listen I'm not horny I'm not
trying to jerk off I just think that
promises made promises kept
do you know what I mean I'm surprised
I'm surprised by your take but I respect
it and it's a I think we should boycott
doja cat until we see the titties okay
Dan you haven't chimed in and Zach I
want to know what everyone thinks what
that if we rode titties or not yes well
I didn't i'm not owed anything because i
neither I didn't listen to the song
people who listen to the song Dan
or are they owed no I'm kind of with the
in like if you really believe that
you're kind of a here you're a doofus
let's be real I just don't find a claim
to be down believable Zach I know where
you fall I mean of course it's
unbelievable what what popstar would
ever do that dude a ton of pop says hey
what's the precedent for pop star
showing titties well that's what was so
incredible about it but no there's a lot
of pop star to show titties when you
talking about I could like them I mean
anyone Miley Cyrus just exposed ready
she's like straight-up veggie ah yeah
Lady Gaga like she's butt ass naked are
you saying like their outfits are
extremely Nate or but there's like a
trillion images of Miley Cyrus naked
I've seen them Lady Gaga's definitely
been there good
arguments are very valid here because on
one hand you gotta love that there's
this horny kids that are upset well
people who are genuinely upset I think
are ridiculous exactly so you gotta love
that
yeah like the people were genuinely
upset at Bell Delphian was was quite
funny so that's that Zak it could give
my take I mean I'm not a fan of doja cat
or know her music but I promise
something your promises made promises
kept
it's simple it's simple mathematics here
folks it's just a human condition that
we all live in the Golden Rule
it wasn't the promise wasn't so
outrageous that it was would be
interpreted as unbelievable that's my
problem with it show some teddy number
one song and outrageous wrote an
outrageous achievement for N and
outrageous reward let's move on though
Jacquet lied to the world and she must
be we need to do a change.org to suspend
to to boycott all of her music from now
on Joey salads was banned from Twitter
now my heart goes out to poor Joey but I
was laughing quite a bit Joey salads if
anyone spent any time on Twitter in the
past six months or something you've seen
that Joey salads has been spamming the
mother living God out of any political
posts Trump tweets AOC tweets whatever
it is Joey salad leaves like a really
corny obvious pandering comment that
gets just like likes from you know it's
like the most obvious comment you can
leave when you're pandering to one
political side right and then under that
he would go subscribe to my podcast the
dude must have been posting like a
thousand times a day and here here's an
example of some what's up
I love Joe he's always scheming oh yeah
when he got banned Joey salads was
trending under food it's [ __ ]
hilarious
rip Joey salads try to blow job with a
gas station tire inflator but gotta dip
stuck exploding his balls and dick what
the [ __ ] was this copypasta Dan I saw
them just somebody posted it up so and
then another one Society now that Joey
salads is banned from Twitter it's a
perfect utopia very happy I can stop
seeing Joshua for Congress and Joey
salads under every vaguely political
tweet that's apparently there's someone
else who got banned too but I will
attain a that dude that dude was like
some guy who was running he was like a
left-wing dude who was supposed to be
running for Congress and he's constantly
asking for money and I think he just
likes Twitter yeah but the funny thing
is that well Joey
I guess Joey texted me when this happen
and he didn't want me to think that he
died giving himself a [ __ ] with a gas
station later I got stuck so he texted
me to let me know that whatever I was
hearing wasn't true they could look good
he just got he got banned for spamming
he wanted me to know that thank you
and I asked him do you think it was
politically motivated he said no he
didn't so that was refreshing said he
didn't think it was politically
motivated think it was just for spamming
maybe about the text
he doesn't believe it is that really
what he's saying publicly I feel like
there's no yeah he was showing me how
pissed drinking Nazi was number one
trending which was so funny because
every time Joey solids would leave one
of his comments there was always other
people that followed him around and
posted pictures of him in the Nazi or
him drinking his own pee yeah there was
a collage of him in a Nazi flair and
drinking his own pee my background right
now yeah right let's see here I wanted
to do the p1 but I feel like actually
okay so so I don't want to misquote him
he said they banned me for spam I assume
it's because I replied to all the tweets
saying to follow me and sup to my
podcast but I've been doing this for six
months and those two you always get
reportable Twitter was never he was
saying they never warned him so he was
salt he was upset that they didn't ever
warn him and I said do you think it's a
conspiracy he said [ __ ] to do right why
don't they well how about just don't
spam I kind of agreed that it was pretty
spammy but then he said I don't think
it's a conspiracy that's what he said I
just think it's not transparent the way
they banned me out of nowhere but the
good news for Joe six months the good
news for Joey is that he has an appeal
pending so we eagerly await to see the
result of that will he work his way back
onto the platform I doubt it go the way
of so many other Trump reply guys oh
there's a long rich history of them
being banned yeah there was like I don't
know if you remember a few years ago
there was these two brothers they're
like identical twins that would reply to
every Trump tweet but like sir you're
gonna go to jail soon sir you know what
I'm talking about
Ian you would know it doesn't ring a
bell uh they have some like weird name
the the crass brothers or something like
this so across those political lines of
the banner right there
since teens the crash and that's the
craz enstein brothers these two dopes
that were like total like Robert Mueller
is coming for you bro
like just spamming Trump every you know
within ten seconds of him posting and
then they eventually they both got
banned for like vote manipulation
oh we're buying likes and all kinds of
slow that's embarrassing though Joe no
and up going up to heaven to meet the
crescents dude anyone that Wade's into
the respond responses to Trump tweets is
asking to to ruin their own day I mean
that is just such a cesspool it's the
worst like there's a whole there's a
whole like cast of characters you see
the same people all the time there's
that stupid like NPR looking dude like
Jeff Jeff Tish I mean Joey somehow like
the top reply every single time yeah
Joey was always every single time the
top ones you know what I love I agree
it's cuz you follow him but I would see
that all the same character he was that
I I fall I think I follow but I muted
him because I can't stand his political
well you don't have to worry about him
anymore yeah thank you I'd love to see a
Broadway musical about Trump look the
whole Trump reply squad like the
Conservatives the Liberals and then
Daddy trauma do dr. goo yeah yeah how
dare you sir
how dare you sir I will say - Joey's
defense I do have to just speak in honor
of the truth with the hashtag pissed
drinking Nazi now I will say that this
image of jewelry with the swastika on
his arm first of all if you plan on
running for political office don't go in
public wearing a swastika in your arm
for any reason it's a hilarious image
but at any rate he would what his
experiment was is like i'ma go I'm gonna
go to a trump rally dressed as Nazis as
a Nazi and see if they accept me or or
rebuke me and the Trump so that
his experiment right so just to give
context support goe he's not a Nazi but
it is hilarious image and the experiment
wasn't that great to begin with oh no
that's the other half of that hashtag is
true piss drinking is irrefutable and
that is the main part here not to just
up his drink his own pee how many people
because on all those Trump tweets he
would reply them people replied to him
with that gif of himself this is so
funny now how many random people in the
United States have seen Joey P Andrew
millions I would say I love this tip
girl who tweeted this goodbye Joey
salads history cannot see she links to
my video about how he faked the Trump
cart car prank and then people get angry
apparently because I'm I'm not like
politically were also anymore yeah I'm a
Nazi - so then she has to quantify her
original post by saying I used this
video because I remembered it showed the
behind the scenes of the social
experiment I am NOT saying H 3 is the
top tier of sources he just happened to
use the clip I was looking for so she is
not endorsing me to be clear I just had
the she's already cancelled though oh
here's a link here's a link of Joey
talking about being banned on his
podcast the raging Patriot according
this I got banned from Twitter and I was
using Twitter for the growth and the
left got so happy that I got banned they
actually started trending pissed
drinking Nazi and I got all the way up
to number two beloved
it's awesome Wow is that so fun Twitter
from I just I just love this pit I mean
this is a totally unexpected pivot to go
into political commentary this is not
trying to sell and 95 non-existing mask
oh yeah yeah dude
no it's come on Joey's trying to make an
honest living even if there's colleagues
well I guess it's really well yes some
some of his contemporaries I have
committed one much worse transgressions
am I the left rate by trending me number
two within the real Times the Left
doesn't work because yes behind I
greatly appreciate Rhea Pappas and it's
gonna be hard for me to grow my podcast
now without having any Twitter audience
so if you guys can please help me out
you can share my podcast rate of 5 stars
and like it do whatever you can do to
help me get the word out there because
orange anyway grow is if you guys I love
that his only growth strategy was
spamming Twitter he's like I'm so [ __ ]
now keep on doing my show so today
Twitter ban me and this they said hello
Joey salads has been suspended for
violating Twitter rules specifically for
violating our rules against platform
manipulation in spans sounds about right
now use Twitter services in a matter
intended to artificially amplify or
suppress information or engage in
behavior that manipulates oh yeah yeah
I'm gonna skip this but if you want more
if you want Joey salads political
commentary the raging Patriot you will
not be seeing Joey salad spam on Twitter
anymore unfortunately but we do wish him
the best because why do we wish oh he
sells the best because he took pepper
spray in the face for charity god damn
it and we cherished that moment forever
[Music]
we will always have that listen that
finally a little bit relieved to not
have to say those stuff on Twitter all
the time yes we are stood too far he
pushed it way too far he had to know
that this day was coming he can't sit
there an act shocked too much dude
there's so many there's a limit to the
cringe bro there's so many stories what
the [ __ ] I'm like not haha I don't know
where to go from here because I'm kind
of done talking like I reach a certain
point where yeah I feel like we have to
talk about 6:9 mad let's book QB on
offer next time QB I'm never gonna talk
about it cuz I'll get so I'll get so
I'll get so [ __ ] I get so worked up
about QB we be we be whatever you qui be
maybe these would be these morons that
spend a billion dollars on the dumbest
thing ever and it's totally failing I'm
not gonna get into that that's a whole
black hole okay also the name sucks qui
be everything
it's short for quick bite qui be wipe I
just call it quick bite hmmm quick bite
I'd be better than qui be probably
sounds more like a food delivery service
but at least it means something and you
can remember it maybe sounds like a I
don't know
Takashi okay Ian listen carefully
because you are definitely the resident
expert here on all this [ __ ] Takashi 6-9
was released out of jail because of CO
vid 19 now Takashi 69 went to jail for
what was it what was his original crime
but he snitched on all of his gang
members and they the racketeering right
yeah yeah I think yeah I was like a RICO
charge with all these guys all gang
affiliations multiple things so he got
he just kind of got swept up in some
general gang charges it sounds like or
was he explicitly involved in it was it
was rude
by a good amount if this didn't happen
he was supposed to be let out in August
holy [ __ ]
so he ratted out all of his gang members
and the DEA was like cool dude
six months you're good anyway original
sentence was two years that's a huge
difference he was looking at 35 to life
man
man I'd snitch out my own [ __ ]
grandma to go from 35 to life to two
years I'd snitchy loud
I'd be like yeah she did it you did it
we go to jail for life reveal of course
I would say I'm not saying nothing to
you Pig I tell you or write or die yeah
but luckily we don't sell weapons and
[ __ ] my point being first of all you all
would never sell you out I would never
sell you out and I hope you would know
that I was kidding but the point being
is that presented with two years versus
35 to life boy that's a good deal yeah
so he snitched everyone out and then
because of co vid 19 is ravaging prisons
because of people are just packed in
like sardines perfect place for kovat to
spread they've been letting out a lot of
row low risk offenders with what their
sentence is almost up a lot of people
have been getting out early on house
arrest some people for example are Kelly
Bill Cosby they tried their best even
Harvey they did not get out judge said
uh-uh
but Takashi did get out and I'm sure
that a lot of people want to kill him
and that's gonna be really interesting
to follow I wonder how long he'll
survive do you think he'll be killed Ian
I mean I'm sure he's being watched over
very carefully I mean I don't know but I
think he'll be being very safe yeah I
think he's gonna be murdered so anyway
he dropped
he dropped a music video called Guba
which I didn't think was a very good
track to be honest in what did you think
about Guba I did yeah I mean he's
doesn't seem it doesn't seem like much
of a talent if I'm just maybe I'm being
obtuse but I don't I didn't really I
don't see the appeal the lyrics are just
so dumb that it's funny oh let me read
the lyrics cuz obviously I can't play
the song for you but let me read some
some of the lyrics from Guba and you
guys can tell me what you think but I
was confused how do you release a music
video under house arrest cuz there's a
music video yeah that's a good question
you know now we now we also noticed that
6-9 gets the n-word pass we were I mean
he's Hispanic but he says that n-word
now this is an interesting phenomenon
what is your comment on that
in I mean I can't really speak on that I
don't know it's not do you find it
interesting though that this guy gets
the n-word pass I mean like I said I
don't know I can't it's not my call to
even to make in any way one way or the
other I don't know I find it interesting
from an outsider perspective that he
gets the pass but I'm assuming it's just
because of his gang affiliation but now
that he's ratted out his gang gang
members I wonder if the n-word pass as
being is should be revoked at this point
in time I don't know it's not my pass to
give or take away or good answer I was
testing it well it's hard to read the
lyrics because there's a lot of n words
but let's say I tell he starts by saying
I tell a n-word don't dick ride don't
blick ride
what is blick riding
Ian I think a blick is like a gun okay
leave it to the double thick thighs twin
sisters drop it down and wobble wobble
up mummy booted up she get down and
gobble gobble up cuz my money up slide
slide in the Bentley truck a the rat the
Wraith truck a your bestie is a
dick-sucker i big dub her can I tell you
a salami llama I Luke him oh he's seeing
you big hater you nothing but a hater
cloud chaser Caligula are you dumb
stupid or dumb huh oh right I right I
saw that lyric was trending yeah yeah I
saw I saw dumb stupid or dumb on Twitter
I was like what is that yeah he asked
are you dumb stupid or dumb it's like
well haha [ __ ] I'm laughing cuz you big
mad big mad
see it in your face crybaby [ __ ] you
big sad so now the big mad and the big
sad is just been stuck with me big man
are you dumb stupid or dumb huh
yeah you got some money but you still
[ __ ] ugly stupid listen when I talk
you better listen we can make them dance
but cata
what spicata slide over do the cha-cha
and gotcha is a type of Italian bread it
usually has like some kata
no but kata here a genius defined it for
me but kata is a style of social dance
from the Dominican Republic
oh you better correct that then they got
it they got it wrong you just mixed up
achacha and baccata don't play that off
I telli and where's big dumb wow dude
stupid or dumb stupid and then he ends
very powerfully by saying haha [ __ ] I'm
laughing cuz you big mad see it in your
face crybaby [ __ ] you big sad and words
tweeting about me got me trending [ __ ]
you big sad tell me how I ratted came
home to a big bag ooh I think people
want him dead and we will continue on
our I want someone to take your reading
of the lyrics and then put it over the
beat I'm gonna be like that mom was
offended by the I love that the good
state yeah he says he did a live stream
that broke instagram records by racking
and more than two million concurrent
viewers damn that's amazing he was
responding to accusations of him being a
rat he said I want to apologize to my
fans because you know what it wasn't
worth it if there was a street code and
there's something called no loyalty and
snitching and all that I get it but
where was the loyalty when you were
sleeping with my baby mother he said
hinting at rumors evolving former
manager shouty and his baby mama
where was the loyalty when you were
caught on the wiretap trying to kill me
Oh doesn't sound like well it's at all
where's a loyalty when you tried to
kidnap my mother that didn't sound like
loyalty where was the low two when you
stole millions of dollars I ask you this
good questions I get it don't fire don't
fight fire with fire he went on I'm
sorry but what did I do wrong be loyal
to a n-word that was my effing my baby
moms be loyal to an n-word that
kidnapped me beat the [ __ ] out of me on
video and everything did that happen he
got his ass beat on video maybe we don't
have access to that I'm supposed to be
loyal to that you know what it is
you don't want to accept the fact that
those is all true facts you understand
why I snitched you don't want to
understand I understand why you said she
didn't want to be 35 years in prison you
wanted to be 2 years in prison I [ __ ]
get that people who are after this dude
for being a snitch now this so he
actually had to be relocated after he
was making ah he was on his balcony it
is I guess
as secret location he took this photo on
his balcony not a discreet outfit by the
way
just absurdly bright on baby blue and
holding what looks to be probably
$20,000 in cash and then a girl posted
this video on Twitter which is just
hilarious
[Music]
so this she reported him taking that
photo I posted on Twitter and then he
was like oh [ __ ] I got a move now
because people are gonna come kill me
Takashi's attorney wouldn't that be
crazy if he got murdered because of that
girl's video I wonder how she I'm
posting it on Instagram that's a good
point it's not really on her to uh to
know better his attorney said that he
was located because of the leak for
security reasons we're told that the
feds were made aware of the move it's
quite a predicament technically he is
not violating his house arrest by being
on the balcony
it's the neighbors around him that docks
him that said he should know better yes
of course it's not prudent of him to
step out into the public like that
Takashi's got a huge problems from
across the way took yadda-yadda-yadda
he's an he oh he is in witness
protection I thought before it said he
no he's not violating house arrest he is
in witness protection but he really
should not be going out onto the balcony
with the rainbow hair and the Instagram
and all that and I really do think this
guy's gonna be murdered I'm gonna I'm
just
I know it's insensitive and it's dark
but I'm willing to put to predict right
now and even to bet money with somebody
that he will not make it through the end
of this year anyone want to take me up
on that a death bet death pool anyone
there's a little moral yeah the only
reason I even bring it up honestly is
because on her big mad yeah he was
actually moved or they found him again
they did yeah I just put it in there
they found him again I yeah here's a
video his new address has been leaked a
second time oh he cuz he's got all these
outrageous sports cards I'm sure and
he's got a bat he's got like a blue
Rolls Royce right a Jeep a bright yellow
Ferrari oh my god bro you better get out
of there quick takashi attempts to
donate two hundred thousand dollars to
no kid hungry and it's rejected at first
I was like man they should just take the
money feed the kids but then I read the
rationale they say we are grateful for
his generous offer to donate to no kids
hungry but we have informed his
representatives that we have declined
the money as a child focus campaign is
our policy declined funding from donors
who activity do not align with our
mission and values that makes sense
you're kind of sending the wrong message
you know like yeah we'll take money from
gangs he also has a with the note the
child thing the no Kid Hungry he also
has charges involving a minor right
that's not good
it wasn't good whatever was ever met I
just remember that he videoed like some
16 Earl Bray I was a 13 year old and he
was oh wow yeah that guy should be in
jail what the [ __ ] I just sent you the
Wikipedia thing about it
okay let's the sewer last segment here
and finally guys I'm sad shredder that's
so loud maybe we can have you take them
out back and finally I am sad to say
that GOG formerly the artist formerly
known as filthy Frank is over people
have just realized that Joe G is filthy
Frank and kpop stands of course were
directly on that to cancel him although
I will say I kind of think it's a high
compliment to Joe G that there's a lot
of people that never knew what filthy
Frank is or that he is filthy Frank that
means that there's a lot of people out
there who are just enjoying his music
and not thinking anything about his
which I think ultimately is what he
wanted as a performer so the fact that
kpop stands are trying to cancel him for
being filthy Frank I think is actually a
high compliment to what he's achieved as
musical artist that being said it is
funny here's a Newsweek article about it
Joe G fans have learned the truth about
filthy Frank and it isn't pretty we've
got this car called garbage is it here's
a job when we put together Joe g
literally has a song where he says the
n-word with a hard ER like you cannot be
serious
there's more don't come in my mentions
talking about is just satire y'all can't
take a joke these days man I don't give
a [ __ ] this [ __ ] isn't funny at all so
get the
[ __ ] out of here with that and for you
non-blacks non-blacks coming my mentions
just get the hell out you don't get to
say the n-word I find it offensive you
insult still my mentions after two days
she looks Asian by the way I mean
because well it's a k-pop right it's a
cape right it's not the picture of the
person right over the past two days Jo
jeez over party has been trending on
Twitter pulling in over twenty-one
thousand tweets an account called Jin's
Jin's all be tweeted out they're shocked
that Miller had said the N word and I
Blake I guess this original tweet which
I think she erased probably right
because ultimately you see a lot of
these such and such as canceled like a
it's actually pic subtraction from
people just clowning on the original
poster and I think that's what happened
in this case is that she ended up
erasing all of her original tweets about
it but what was weird is that this same
girl who oh what the hell is this I'm
really disgusted right now oh my god you
what the f that's him and then the same
girl which is really interesting she
says as a black person my view is that
his lyrics are contextual to the
character he was portraying rather not
hear it
but I'm not mad nor willing to cancel
him and then she responded I swear to
God she just said [ __ ] which is a
derogatory term for a black person it's
not crazy I'm not really following this
so she says for all you the girl says
for all you non-blacks coming into my
mansions just get the hell out you don't
get to say what I find offensive okay
then a black dude said well I'm not
offended I would rather not hear it but
I'm not mad nor willing to cancel him
and she called him a [ __ ] mr. Koontz she
quote tweeted him what the
that's so racist but that concludes our
show ending on a light note thank you
everybody for watching I hope you have a
fantastic week a glorious weekend I wish
that everybody gets gainfully employed
that this virus miraculously disappears
and either I would never snitch on you
don't want to go on record saying that I
would serve life and present life in
prison for you showed your true colors
and I am big sad big Matt but Ella if
you go out selling schedule six drugs I
can't save you I can't save you if
you're doing met big crimes like
schedule six Advil
street crime anyway guys thank you so
much for watching and we will see you
next week we are working on HD video I'm
not sure when it's gonna drop but
there's something to look forward to but
I think it's a good one what do you
think nada
think nothing can't say
[Music]
all right
guitar
[Music]
you
you
I had a idea when I was on the toilet
earlier and I want to know if it's a
good idea go ahead all right
it's called die py peas all right it's a
diaper and built into the diaper is one
baby white so when you go to change the
diaper you pull out the wipe and clean
in there little good idea you cut out
when you got to the climax you you go to
change their diaper and there's a wipe
inside of it you pull out the wipe you
clean their little butthole and then you
throw it away so I'll tell you what's
wrong with this idea and then you can
work on it further usually a baby poops
you're gonna need more than one wife I
mean there's no world and one in which
one wipes enough to clean that okay
never
I got like three at best at best
but and then a lot of the times the baby
poop is super messy and you'll have
what's called blowouts where it just
goes all the way up their back okay but
so for those reasons I'm out oh yeah how
are you gonna keep the the wipe moist
though we'd have to have some sort of
seal yeah you you rip it and pull the
wipes out well wait the baby's gotta
have a wet a moist diaper on them no cuz
it's like no it's contained within wait
you have to seal them what is this an
intervention
yeah he's pitching a thing to us I don't
like the idea
[Music]
Thank You Zach I thank you I should
really have a point before you start
pitching yeah kid brother you want the
diaper to be breathable and light too
and so this is just gonna add weight to
it and we'll make it less breathable
because I'm a sir
because you want to keep it moist so I'm
assuming it's gonna need to be some kind
of pouch right it's a sealed pouch yo
sure that is not it's not gonna be
flexible uncomfortable hmm I mean the
wipes are a little you know I don't know
they're not really rigid that's true I I
get the concept so like when you go to
it like a barbecue restaurant they give
you those like ones in there right
imagine having that pack in your
underwear oh man why would you want
that's like built like that why why'd
why babies build it into your man's box
yeah this might be better for Zach
actually in one location the diaper you
pull it off you don't you don't need an
okay you don't understand
you still need a clean they need a
cleaning station yeah you have a station
with both baby wipes and diapers and
white mint and all this [ __ ] like as
a parent you need to change
you still need to carry the clean
diapers with you so you might as well
carry the wipes - is this a to-go item
this isn't every use item yeah it's like
a convenience thing I just I'm not
terribly inconvenienced by having a pack
of baby wipes you kind of need a pack of
baby wipes anyway all the time because
they get so dirty would you could store
them on their shirts and pants and you
could hide pouches built in all over
yeah
where on the diaper with the pouch be
I'm not sure do you know the anatomy of
a diaper yeah I mean you'd have I'm not
a diaper engineer right